trump is racist because they said he's  racist he hasn't done anything racist  but they've said he's racist to the  point where trump's now a racist that's  now true these people now can literally  bend reality in real time power corrupts  and absolute power corrupts absolutely  these people have so much control so  much power they decide they decide truth  at this point it's not about truth is  subjective true false doesn't exist  right if everyone in the world were to  simultaneously agree that two plus two  equals five then two plus two now equals  five it doesn't matter if math doesn't  work anymore the whole world believes  two plus two equals five that's now true  if they control what people see and  control how people think then they  control what's true and what's false